hồi trước em có được bài của một nhà BNCCT tháng 26
các bạn có bài được 2 phần biển thì họ xét ạ
bài của BNCCT có báo về sự bày báo khác xứng đáng nhé
có thể là ở bài phần đầu có được bày báo dẫn dụng vào việc kết hợp 2 cơ chế
nhất là về...
các bạn có thể xem màn hình thấy không?
thấy
bài rồi nhưng mà kế hoạch tiếp theo là gì nhỉ? bài nào nữa nhỉ?
Có thể là một bài ở hội thảo FCK và xây một bài nữa vào cái nâng lên một tí là tập trí và hướng dịp
Như thế được không ạ?
Điểm đổi trình sửa bài báo sẽ không thay đổi về phương pháp, một loại của phương pháp đề xuất
Bài này là bài A tổng đấy đúng không ạ?
Dạ vâng, bài A tổng nhất là xóa lại mục đồ của việc để đồng chứa ở trong bài báo
Thứ hai là bổ sung một số thực nghiệm phát triển yêu cầu
Như là làm rõ về hướng về phạm vi áp dụng cũng như là các khẳng chế của phương pháp
Báo thầy là các ý kiến của phản viện thì em đã tổng hợp thành 8 nhóm vấn đề chính, nhất là liên quan đến việc ở đây phản viện là bản, chứ không có số chỗ đang tạo tầm sát thứ phát lệch xuất luôn vượt trội, kết quả giữa các bộ dữ liệu vẫn chưa vượt trội hoàn toàn.
Thứ hai là về khả năng vận hành thực tế, tức là tuyệt lời trong một bộ dữ liệu đấy là S, cái lớp đấy là cao, nhưng mà cái Quotation, nếu mà chỉ nhấn mạnh về cái Income Channel, về cái dữ liệu Quotation, thì ta sẽ phản biệt, kỳ ra đấy là có một tỷ lệ nhận diện tất công trong 1,5 năm.
Phần biển lấy nhu cầu để kiểm tra về độ nhảy của cúi tàu này
Thứ tư là bí cơ, đấy là thiên lệch cho lựa chọn ở trong trận diện
Tức là em tiếp tải diện cho một cuốn dữ liệu nên là họ lấy nhu cầu để làm rõ hơn về chỗ này
Các nhóm tiếp theo, các nhóm tiếp theo liên quan đến việc tỷ lệ kê đến tham gia vào công bằng sử lý
Đối với dữ liệu này thì có một số giá trị ở dạng bình thiếu, làm rõ hơn về chỗ này
Em đã tiến hành sử lý đầy đủ các nghi lược của phần biển
sau khi em tìm cách cụ thể hơn về từng phần biệt luật từ cái nội dung em đã tìm sửa
khi bắt đầu phần biệt đấy là có một số vấn đề là cách diễn giải trong nội dung của cái bài báo
thì ở phần trước thì một số câu có thể khiến cho người đọc có thể hiểu sai rằng là khi mà kết hợp cả hai phương pháp đấy là
SATE, UNVEILING IMPLEMENTATION và cái LA thì phương pháp đề xuất sẽ tốt hơn từng thực phẩm riêng lẻ
thì em đã tiến hành rà soát và cầm bổ cái trường thái này
5 xem thì đều là dương
Ở đây thì em sử dụng đây là chưa tiến hành bao nhiêu lần
đã sửa trong bài báo đây là 2 cơ chế này sẽ em cái hiệu cụm thường và sai lệch khác nhau ở test server
chuyển vào không gian lập tư nào, còn cái lời ai sẽ tác động vào điều đối với cái vòng lớp
đã sửa lại toàn bộ công chức ở trong cái phần collusion
đềm bố cái khu hoạt địa xuất mình luôn vận tội về cái lợi ích của dữ liệu cũng như là điều vận hành
thứ 2 đấy là tất cả 2 phần biển đều quan tâm đấy là về cái kích hoạt của cái tổ tiên bộ S-Anti-Sep
đúng với lớp MXTM, đây là lớp chiếm ở trong mẫu dữ liệu này
ở bản bật đầu em nhấn mạnh cái DECOR là khoảng 0,9
tuy nhiên phần biệt chỉ ra là PRECISION chỉ khoảng 0,16
điều này có nghĩa là mô hình phát hiện phần lớn các mẫu của
đây là MXTM thật nhưng đồng thời có thể tạo ra rất nhiều cảnh khóa giả
tiếp tục ở đây để xử lý vấn đề này em phân tích phổ sung thêm các thị số
Ví dụ như là Precision Recall, Precise, Precision và ngược quyết định để kiếm 5 lần chạy
Ngược được chọn trên Beneficent và sau đó được đánh giá trên tập test để sử dụng lượng test để chọn hướng
Tại điểm vận hành hiện tại thì Precision khoảng 0,170 trong tài liệu Recall
Ở đây là chức pháp của em, được lựa chọn thêm về tiêu chí đánh giá là Precise của 5.6
Phương pháp nghiên cứu là xa cơ cơ, điện thoại là 0.4 phút chí
Tiếp lệch ở đây cũng là thân của người ta nhưng mà cũng là con lớn
Vì vậy kẻ riêng sẽ được đặt các ký số liên quan đến Average Precision
Tiếp theo đấy là thẩm số tàu Wyss Thuật Minh
Trước đó em sử dụng thẩm số tàu bằng 0.5
Sau đó phân biệt đặt ra một câu hỏi là liệu giá trị này có sự phù hợp
Để mà biết thì em đã thực hiện thêm khám sát theo 5 giá trị
Tổ hình chạy 3 lần, tổng hợp tổng tộng là 1,45 lần chạy, đó là tổng bài để làm sử dụng 1,5 thì tiến hành qua mặt trước đi đánh giá cái tập test với sử dụng. Những cái thức nghiệm của em chỉ là trả lời cho câu hỏi đây là thêm lệnh sản xuất cao bằng khi mà đã test ạ.
khi tiến hành kinh nghiệm thì có thể thấy là khi mà tàu tăng lên thì cái Depo có xu hướng giảm
nhưng mà sự Depo có xu hướng nó tăng nhưng mà cái Condition và Ecology nó giảm
thì điều này có thể thấy đấy là tác dụng tàu này là một cái tác dụng mình có thể điều chỉnh
thuộc vào cái việc đấy là mình muốn ngôi phương pháp mình đấy là đặt cái Depo cao hay là muốn Condition
thì mình sẽ đưa hướng mà em sẽ tiến hành cải thiện trong các bài báo tiếp theo
là em sẽ xâm thuận tao này thích nghị với từng bộ dữ liệu
nên cái nhận xét tiếp theo là liên quan đến việc lựa chọn lớp target
từ phần đầu tiên thì mỗi bộ dữ liệu thì em có lại mức được xác định trước
để mà tiến hành theo dõi cái target
thì phần biển cho rằng đấy là nếu mà chỉ đánh giá đến một cái tương trọng trước
thì có thể xuất hiện cái hướng đấy là mình lựa chọn chứng đoán
bổ sung một số cái đánh giá rộng hơn cho, đấy là rộng hơn hoặc là cái nhóm lớp mà khả năng thì rộng hơn và lựa chọn đẳng bằng
nên cái đoạn sẽ là đánh xét việc mà mình sẽ thức hợp và tiến hành theo việc đấy
đây là liên quan đến cái lần khi Pay sử dụng đấy là một lần nhưng mà tuy nhiên thì server vẫn nhận được một số thông tin số lượng mẫu
như là số lượng mẫu theo từng lớp hoặc số mô hình
công ty này thì thông tin liên quan đến số lượng từng lớp thì bổ sung đấy là đột quyền lên cho server ạ
tôi đã đưa ra một giải pháp để bảo vệ công đoàn liên quan đến vụ súng, liên quan đến đẩy dụng, liên quan đến tổ lịch
ở việc màn này thì em sử dụng lại các kết quả của bao lần đẩy trước
thì em đã đẩy rõ hơn về phần giới hạn nghiên cứu
dữ liệu không đủ nhất thì mình tạo theo phân phối Red List mô phóng
cái này thì mình mới dừng ở con số 50, máy cản tham gia khẩu huấn luyện
mô hình thì hiện tại mình sử dụng một mô đoàn nhiều lớp để mô phóng một số kẻ
kết mạng và sự thay đổi của dữ liệu theo thời gian
Em đã trình bày rõ phần nội dung này trong nguyên phần hành trình nghiên cứu
Và xác định đây là một hướng phát hiện tiếp theo
Nhiên cứu của một số các...
Xin em được báo cáo về đề án nghiên cứu mô hình gan cho sinh dữ liệu tấn công SQ Injection
Nhằm nâng cao mô hình phát hiện dựa trên học máy
Phần trình bày của em sẽ gồm có tổng cộng 7 phần
Đầu tiên là sẽ đặt vấn đề
Tiếp theo là em sẽ nói qua về dữ liệu nghiên cứu
Khảo sát mô hình
Tiếp theo là em sẽ nói
Giới thiệu qua về các đề xuất cải tiến
Mô hình em lựa chọn là
SequinGAN
Em sẽ đến với phần phân tích kết quả thực nhiệm
Và sẽ kiểm tra dữ liệu
Kiểm tra kết quả
Thông qua từng lửa và cuối cùng là đi đến kết luận
Em xin bắt đầu
Đầu tiên là đặt vấn đề
Thì tấn công SQL Injection
là việc chèn má SQL để thao túng câu lệnh truy vấn
Mục tiêu là sẽ truy cập các dữ liệu trái phép
và là một dạng lỗ hổng web nguy hiểm
Hiện tại thì dữ liệu khi được sử dụng để huấn luyện
thì gặp một vấn đề đó chính là bị mất cân bằng dữ liệu
Trong đó dữ liệu tấn công thực tế thì ít hơn rất nhiều so với dữ liệu thông thường
và tạo ra một sự mất cân bằng vô cùng lớn
Và mô hình học máy có thể sẽ học thiên về các lớp đa số và bỏ qua một số mẫu đặc biệt
Một số mẫu có độ độc nhất cao và có cấu trúc ngư pháp nó phức tạp
Nếu để tiếp tục dữ liệu được huấn luyện bởi các dữ liệu thông thường
Thì sẽ bỏ qua các câu lệnh tấn công phức tạp
Và nếu kẻ tấn công biết được sẽ chủ động tạo ra các câu lệnh tấn công phức tạp
Để có thể vượt qua được các mô hình học máy
Vì vậy em đã đặt ra việc là mình sẽ cần phải bổ sung dữ liệu SQL Injection đa dạng
Và nâng cao khả năng học và phát hiện của SQL Injection của các mô hình học máy
Thì em xin giới thiệu qua, à sẽ nói qua về các hướng phát hiện SQL Injection mà em đang tìm hiểu
Thì sẽ có 2 hướng, một là mình sử dụng luôn các bộ lệnh sẵn
Khách hoạt động sẽ là so khớp dữ liệu đầu vào với các dữ liệu tấn công
Yếu điểm là rất là nhanh và có thể áp dụng đa số
Còn nhược điểm là khi có các biến thể mới thì sẽ cần phải cập nhật
Và nếu như không cập nhật thì sẽ không để phát hiện
Và thường là nếu như kẻ tấn công sử dụng các mẫu phức tạp hơn thì sẽ khó nhận biết
Và hướng thứ 2 là theo hướng trí tuệ nhân tạng
Thì có 2 đại diện là học máy hoặc học sâu
thì ưu điểm là mình sẽ linh hoạt hơn
có thể sử dụng chính bộ dữ liệu của mình
mà không sử dụng bộ mà cộng đồng đưa ra
và có thể tự ép cho nó phù hợp với mô hình dữ liệu thực tế
mà không cần phải công khai
nhưng mà nhược điểm là mình sẽ cần một lượng dữ liệu
vô cùng lớn và cần phải chất lượng
thì các nghiên cứu trước đây về việc xử lý mất cân bằng
mà em có dùng để tham vấn
nó chính là dựa trên 2 bài báo mới nhất
thì 1 bài là xử lý mức độ mất cân bằng
trải dài từ 1 trên 10 cho tới 1 trên 1.000
và phương pháp họ sử dụng là SMOTE
và tương tự với bài báo còn lại
cũng là mức độ là từ 200 trên 1
cũng là sử dụng 1 biến thể SMOTE để xử lý
Và kết quả của họ đưa ra là vô cùng tốt
Và bộ dữ liệu mà em sử dụng là bộ dữ liệu tên là SQI V3
Em được lấy trên Kaggle
Đây là bộ dữ liệu phổ biến nhất
Ở trên Kaggle để nói về bài toán SQI
Và có rất nhiều bài báo khoa học tham vần đến bộ dữ liệu này
Về quy mô thì có khoảng hơn 30.000 dữ liệu
Trong đó thì chiếm 1 phần 3 là mẫu tấn công SQI
và 2 phần 3 còn lại là
mẫu dữ liệu SQL thông thường
sau khi đọc qua
các bài báo của những người
đi trước thì em sẽ đề xuất ra
là có 3 tỷ lệ
đầu tiên là tỷ lệ 1 trên 10
thì nghĩa là
cứ có 100 mẫu
thông thường
thì sẽ có 1 mẫu tấn công
mục tiêu của em là em để mức độ
khan hiểm vừa, dữ liệu tấn công
tuy mỏng nhưng mô hình vẫn có thể học ổn định
tiếp theo là mẫu
1 trên 200
Thì khi này là dữ liệu nó sẽ càng thơ thơ
Và cuối cùng là 1 trên 500
Thì đây là mức dữ liệu
Tiệm cận với thực tế
Nơi mà mẫu tấn công
Quan sát được luôn ít hơn
Mẫu thực tế
Thì ở trong mô hình của em
Thì em có hơn 15.000 dữ liệu
Thì sẽ chỉ có khoảng
31 dữ liệu tấn công
Tiếp theo là các mô hình
Các phương pháp mà em
Tìm hiểu và triển khai
Thì đầu tiên là phương pháp cơ sở
Thì đó chính là phương pháp SMODE em đã có nói ở phần bên trên
Thì họ sẽ nội suy từ các mô dữ liệu có sẵn
Và đây sẽ là phương pháp dùng làm mốc để so sánh
Tiếp theo là các phương pháp sử dụng mạng đối nghịch tạo sinh
Thì đầu tiên là nhóm sinh đặc trưng
Đại diện sẽ là mô hình GAN và CTGAN
Các mô hình này sẽ sinh dữ liệu dưới dạng vector đặc trưng
và sẽ cần phải chuyển đổi ngược để tạo ra chuỗi tấn công
và một nhóm là sinh thẳng chuỗi dữ liệu luôn
đại diện là mô hình SQLGAN
phương pháp của mô hình này sẽ là sinh trực tiếp
chuỗi đơn vị mã hóa, các chuỗi token
và có thể sinh
thẳng ra dữ liệu và có thể đánh giá trực tiếp luôn
Đầu tiên em xin phép giới thiệu qua về mô hình SMOKE
Đây là mô hình xử lý việc các lớp đa số nhiều hơn hẳn các hẳn lớp thiểu số
Mô hình này đầu tiên với mỗi mẫu thiểu số sẽ sử dụng một thuật toán để tìm các mẫu thiểu số khác ở gần nó nhất
hay còn gọi là K lắng giềng
sau đó là sẽ tạo ra mẫu tổng hợp
bằng cách lấy dữ liệu ngẫu nhiên
nằm trên điểm
nối giữa dữ liệu gốc
và dữ liệu ca nắng riêng ngẫu nhiên đó
và sẽ lặp đi lặp lại
cho tới khi đủ dữ liệu
khi mà đủ dữ liệu
biến cho lớp thiểu số
được bổ sung đầy đủ
để tránh việc mất cân bằng
tiếp theo là em sẽ nói dịu
về mô hình gan
thì ở đây bắt đầu từ không gian tiềm ẩn
thì sẽ có một vector ngẫu nhiên
được đưa vào bộ sinh
là bộ sinh ở đây là một mạng neuron nhiều lớp
để tạo ra dữ liệu sinh
cùng với đó thì dữ liệu huấn luyện
cũng lấy mẫu thật
để làm dữ liệu
thì cả mẫu thật lân mẫu giả
cũng được đưa vào trong bộ phân biệt
là bộ màu xanh ở giữa
để đánh giá đâu là mẫu thật
đâu là mẫu giả
Kết quả của bộ phân biệt sẽ được dùng để tính hàm mất mát
Từ sau đó dựa vào kết quả của 2 mất mát này
Thì sẽ được lan truyền ngược lại để có thể tiếp tục quy trình
Và từ đó tạo ra rất nhiều vòng lọc
Nơi mà bộ sinh sẽ cố gắng tạo ra dữ liệu càng giống thật
Còn bộ đánh giá thì sẽ càng phân biệt chính xác hơn
Đây là 2 công thức
Thì trong đó phần bôi xanh lá sẽ đại diện cho dữ liệu gốc
Và phần bôi màu vàng sẽ đại diện cho dữ liệu tạo sinh
Thì ở đây ở bên trên hàm mất mát của bộ sinh sẽ tính điểm
Cho dữ liệu tạo... hàm mất mát... em nhầm ạ
Phần bên trên là hàm mất mát của bộ phân biệt
thì trong hàm này sẽ có phần màu xanh lá là dữ liệu gốc được lấy từ dữ liệu
và dữ liệu tạo sinh thì sẽ là phần màu vàng được lấy từ dữ liệu tạo ra
thì ở đây thì hàm mất mát của bộ phân biệt sẽ tính điểm cho dữ liệu gốc
và tính điểm trừ cho dữ liệu tạo sinh
mục tiêu là tối đa hóa dữ liệu gốc và tối thiểu hóa việc nhận nhầm dữ liệu tạo sinh
Còn đối với hàm ất mát của bộ sinh thì sẽ chấm điểm cao cho dữ liệu tạo sinh với mục tiêu là tối đo hóa dữ liệu sinh nhằm tăng khả năng thuyết phục trong các lần lặp lại tiếp theo
Tiếp theo là mô hình CTGAN
Thì thay vì mô hình gan cũ thì mô hình CTGAN sinh dữ liệu dạng bảng và sẽ có các cột và các hàng
Điểm khác biệt so với mô hình gan gốc là trước khi sinh thì hệ thống sẽ chọn ngẫu nhiên một cột làm điều kiện
Sau đó lọc ra để tìm các cái cột mà khớp với các điều kiện đấy
Thì bộ sinh thì sẽ nhận các cái giá trị nhiễu mà có cùng các cái điều kiện
Từ đó sinh ra các dữ liệu giả tương đương các điều kiện đó
Còn các hàm giả, các hàng giả, các dữ liệu giả ở hàng giả và hàng thật
Thì sẽ cùng được đưa vào trong bộ đánh giá
Khi đó sẽ được chấm điểm thay vì chỉ đánh giá mức độ thật giả
Thay vì chỉ phân loại nhịp phân như là mô hình gan
Thì điểm số mà bộ đánh giá được dùng
Sẽ được dùng làm sai số và sẽ được lan truyền ngược lên dòng với mô hình gan cũ
thì ở đây thì sẽ có 2 hàm
thì cũng tương tự
thì cũng tương tự với mô hình gan
chỉ khác là
trong mô hình CT gan
thì thay vì đánh giá
đánh giá phân loại nhịp phân
là được đạt hoặc không
đạt hoặc không đạt thì sẽ tính điểm
thì sẽ tính điểm
thì cuối cùng
là đến mô hình CT quần gan
mô hình CT quần gan
thì ở mô hình CT quần gan nó sẽ khác
là mô hình sinh quần gan sẽ sinh ra dữ liệu dạng chuỗi
nên vì vậy bộ sinh sẽ không xuất phát từ các vector nhiều nữa
mà sẽ có một phần trước là trạng thái pre-chain
hay còn gọi là một bộ sinh trước
để có thể chủ động sinh ra dữ liệu
và sau khi mà có một bộ sinh này sẽ đóng vai trò là bước đầu tiên
để đóng vai trò là một mạng chính sách
và sẽ chủ động sinh ra các chuối giả
thì sẽ gồm
và sẽ dần dần
các cái chuối đấy sẽ được
tiếp nối tiếp nối cho đến khi trở thành
một chuối giả đầy đủ
mà đầy đủ ạ
thì khi đó là cả chuối thật và chuối giả
sẽ được đưa vào bộ phân biệt để chấm
xem liệu có phải là chuối thật hay chuối giả hay không
và bởi vì là
chuối
bộ phân biệt này
chỉ nhận dữ liệu đầy đủ
Nên là khi đó là sẽ cần một phương pháp khác để dẫn lối cho bộ sinh sinh đến dữ liệu cuối cùng
Thế nên là sẽ có thêm một hệ thống lấy mẫu gọi là lấy mẫu Monte Carlo Sampling
Dùng để thử nhiều cách
Sẽ liên tục thử, sẽ liên tục đưa dữ liệu vào trong bộ phân biệt để thử
Cho đến khi mà tạo ra dữ liệu đầy đủ
Và sau khi đó là mô hình, sau khi đó là bộ phân biệt sẽ được cập nhật lại các hàm mất mát để có thể là lan truyền gọt lại như bình thường
Thì ở đây thì là hàm mất mát của bộ phân biệt thì cũng có tính chất giống với cả hai mô hình còn lại
Tuy nhiên là với hàm mất mát của bộ sinh thì nó sẽ có khác biệt là nó sẽ cố gắng cập nhật các cái policy gradient để tăng sát xuất để chọn token dẫn tới việc là sinh ra được dữ liệu mà được chấp nhận tốt hơn.
Thay vì là có một hàm mất mát hẳn hoi
Thì
Ở trong mô hình của em
Thì em sẽ có các chỉ số đánh giá chất lượng
Thì đầu tiên là sẽ có 3 chỉ số
Thì đầu tiên là
Chỉ số về điểm cấu trúc
Thì điểm cấu trúc với mục đích
Là sẽ đánh giá xem là dữ liệu
Có các đặc tính
Có các đặc tính của một payload SQL không
Hay chỉ là sinh ra trôi không hợp lệ
Đồ độc nhất
Là đánh giá dữ liệu sinh ra có thật sự mới hay không
hay chỉ là lặp lại các dữ liệu cũ, độ đa dạng thì sẽ đánh giá xem là mô hình sinh ra có sinh ra được nhiều dạng SQL, Injection khác nhau hay không
hay là chỉ lặp lại một vài dạng có sẵn.
Và cuối cùng là bộ chỉ số đánh giá hiệu quả gồm có Accuracy, Precision Recall và M1.
Thì ở khảo sát ban đầu thì là 3 mô hình ban đầu thì có điểm cấu trúc và độ đa dạng rất là cao
Nhưng mà độ độc nhất thì ở mức 0%
Còn đối với mô hình sequin gan thì lại là ngược lại
Khi mà độ độc nhất thì nó sẽ cao hơn
Nhưng mà điểm cấu trúc và độ đoạn dạng rất là thấp
Điều này thể hiện cho việc là các mô hình, 3 mô hình ban đầu
Smooth, Gan và City Gan
Là do là nội sinh từ dưới liệu gốc
Nên là có điểm cấu trúc rất là cao
Tuy nhiên là không sinh ra được các mẫu có độ sáng tạo hơn
hoặc là không học được các cái mẫu có độ phức tạp cao, nên là độ độc nhất rất là thấp.
Còn mô hình SQL GAN gốc thì lại có khả năng học được các cái mẫu độc nhất đấy
và sinh ra các mẫu có độ sáng tạo và độ phủ cao hơn.
Thế nên em chọn mô hình SQL GAN ở đây làm mô hình phân biệt chính
và sẽ cải thiện để nâng cao điểm cấu trúc và độ đa dạng lên ạ.
Tương tự thì với các chỉ số khác thì các điểm số của các mô hình này cũng khá là cao
Thì đến kết luận thì là 3 mô hình ban đầu thì sẽ có điểm cấu trúc rất là cao
Nhưng mà có trùng lập lớn với bộ dữ liệu gốc
Thì có khả năng tạo dữ liệu mới còn rất hạn chế và gần như chỉ sao chép
Nội sinh là các dữ liệu gốc đã có
Có mô hình si quần gan thì có điểm cấu trúc rất là thấp
tuy nhiên là tỷ lệ trùng lập
không có tỷ lệ trùng lập cao
tuy
nhiên là hay bị ép
về những mẫu có dạng cấu trúc rất là ngắn
và an toàn
và em đã đề xuất là 2 hướng cải thiện
đầu tiên là cải thiện dữ liệu
và em sẽ cải thiện dữ liệu đầu vào
bằng cách tách từng họ tấn công
Bullen, Union, Time và
Aaron
và chuẩn hóa độ dài dữ liệu đầu vào
giúp cho dữ liệu đồng nhất hơn
giúp cho bộ sinh học đúng với các đặc trưng
của từng loại tấn công
tiếp theo là cải thiện về hướng thuật toán
Thì như ở phần trước đã nói thì là mô hình bị ép về sinh ra các kiểu dữ liệu ngắn và an toàn
Chứng tỏ là trong việc huấn luyện thì là mô hình SQLGAN đã có khả năng bị collapse, bị sập
Và nó hướng tới những cái mô an toàn để có thể nhận được điểm tốt
Vì vậy là em cải thiện để token hóa theo các đơn vị có nghĩa
Bổ sung đánh giá cú pháp SQL
thì khi này là bộ đánh giá sẽ không những đánh giá xem là dữ liệu có phải dữ liệu giả hay không
mà còn đánh giá dữ liệu có phải là dữ liệu SQL hay không
bằng cách kết hợp 70% của bộ đánh giá và 30% là điểm cấu trúc SQL
với mục tiêu là cho sinh ra vừa phải giống dữ liệu thật mà cần phải vừa đảm bảo cấu trúc SQL
thì đầu tiên là theo hướng cải thiện dữ liệu thì sẽ có tổng cộng là 6 hướng
Đầu tiên là nhỏ chọn theo cách gốc là chọn theo dữ nguyên thứ tự
Tiếp theo là chọn theo độ dài câu
B thì sẽ đại diện cho việc là ưu tiên các câu có độ dài ngắn
C thì ưu tiên vùng độ dài xuất hiện phổ biến trong tập dữ liệu
Tiếp theo là chọn theo ngẫu nhiên trong vùng đã được khoanh
Thì đầu tiên là sẽ có D là chọn ngẫu nhiên
Ở trong vùng 25-75% độ dài tránh phân mổ quá ngắn hoặc quá dài
và chọn ngẫu nhiên trên toàn bộ tập dữ liệu
và cuối cùng là
chọn theo độ phủ
và sẽ ưu tiên chọn các câu khác biệt nhất
so với những câu đã được chọn trước đó
thì như ở trong mô hình
thì về cải thiện thuật toán
thì như ở bên trên em đã đề xuất
4 phần, thì đầu tiên là phần thứ nhất
là sẽ tăng cường
việc huấn luyện trước bộ sinh
thì khi mà
mô hình có một bộ sinh sẽ có khả
khỏe hơn và có khả năng
đang sinh ra dữ liệu chắc chắn hơn. Tiếp theo là em sẽ tách chuỗi cú pháp SQL thì thay vì mô hình
sẽ cố gắng học các con số như 123 hoặc là các cú pháp thì em sẽ biển nó thành các từ khóa toán tử
để mô hình sẽ chỉ học các cái phần thành phần token trong đó mà không học quá tràn lan các con
số. Tiếp theo là em sẽ chia độ dài thì như ở trong mô hình cũ của tác giả thì tác giả sử dụng độ
Độ dài chuỗi là 20, nghĩa là một câu đệnh payload sẽ được chia làm 20 phần
và sẽ cố gắng học trong 20 phần đấy.
Thì thay vì thế em sẽ tăng lên thành 160 để cho mô hình thay vì học từng câu
mà sẽ phải học đến từng ký tức để có thể tăng khả năng học của mô hình lên.
Và cuối cùng là kết hợp điểm thưởng.
Thì như em đã đề xuất ở bên trên là sẽ chia làm 70%
là nhận định mô hình có giống mẫu gốc hay không
và 3% sẽ là mô hình có thật sự có cấu trúc SQL hay không
thì sau khi chạy xong thì có các kịch bản nổi bật
về mặt kịch bản thuật toán
thì là có kịch bản V7
ở đây thì là cả 2 kịch bản này
thì đều áp dụng trước là huấn luyện trước
tăng cường bộ huấn luyện trước khi sinh
và có bổ sung thêm reward
tuy nhiên V7 thì tập trung vào việc là chuỗi ngắn
và có không tách chuỗi theo cú pháp
còn kịch bản V8 thì là có tăng độ dài chuỗi
và có tách chuỗi theo cú pháp
còn đối với kịch bản cải thiện dữ liệu
thì có 2 kịch bản là B và D
trong đó B thì ưu tiên các câu có độ dài ngắn
và D là chỉ chọn trong vùng ngẫu nhiên
từ 25% đến 75% độ dài tranh phân bổ 2 đầu
và kết quả thực tế thì là
các mô hình đề xuất
thì đã cải thiện được điểm cấu trúc
và độ đa dạng
nhiều tuy nhiên là
tuy một số
các cái family
thì nó có điểm rất là thấp
ví dụ như Bolan và Aaron
thì ở đây em có thể giải thích
là do là hai
family này
thì nó có ngữ pháp
và yêu cầu nó chặt chẽ hơn
nên là mô hình đã không học được
còn những cái phụ pháp khác như kiểu
union và time thì có
có khả năng học tốt hơn và theo các chỉ số đánh giá khác và kết luận khảo sát ban đầu thì là mô
hình si quần gan cải tiến là cải thiện, đã cải thiện được những hạn chế của mô hình si quần
gan cũ và đã đạt được các thông số và đạt được độ cân bằng tốt giữa tính mới và tính hợp lệ của
SQL giảm hiện tượng sụp đổ cấu trúc ở một mức cân bằng cao và ở đây thì kịch bản em chọn và đề
Đó chính là kịch bản dữ liệu D và kịch bản thuật toán V7 và V8
Bởi vì ở đây 2 kịch bản này có độ ổn định cao nhất và nổi bật với cả Bolan và Union
Có tỷ lệ khấu trúc SQL đạt trên 8% và vẫn luôn duy trì tính đồng nhất cao
Cuối cùng là tiếp theo em sẽ đến với quy trình kiểm thử với tương lửa
Sau khi tạo ra những dữ liệu, khi sinh ra được dữ liệu
Em sẽ đưa qua được các bộ rule set
Các cái bộ luật
Của mode security
Để đánh giá
Thì khi này em sẽ coi như
Nếu như nhận đánh giá 403 là bị chặn
Còn nhận đánh giá
Nhận respond là 200
Thì chứng tỏ là không bị chặn
Và được qua
Sau khi nhận được dữ liệu đấy xong
Thì em sẽ chủ động kiểm tra
Xem là dữ liệu thực tế đấy
Nó vượt qua là do là nó là noise
hay là do là nó thật sự vượt qua và còn cấu trúc SQL
thì đầu tiên là đến với mô hình SMOD
thì đây là dữ liệu sinh ra của mô hình SMOD
hầu hết các dữ liệu này đều bị chặn
do là dữ liệu chỉ nội sinh từ dữ liệu gốc
nên là nếu như dữ liệu gốc mà đã có những cái
đã có những cái thành phần phổ biến mà đã bị chặn
thì dữ liệu nội sinh ra cũng sẽ bị chặn
nhưng mà dữ liệu sinh ra của mô hình này
mô hình này thì có hầu hết thì đều bị thiên về Time Bay. Trong đó là có các dấu hiệu như là
Generate Series của Post Grid SQL và Random Blocks của SQLite và đa số các payload thì đều có đều đều
đã có được cái cấu trúc SQL và đều có mục mục đích kỹ thuật tương ứng. Tiếp theo là đến với mô hình
Thì là mô hình này thì nó đã cải thiện hơn và đúng kỹ thuật nhiều hơn
Tuy nhiên là vẫn còn một mô hình bị thiên về hướng Time Bay
Mô hình này thì nó gặp phải vấn đề là nó bị thiếu việc đóng ngữ cảnh
Thì vì vậy là nếu đưa câu lệnh này vào thực tế thì thật sự không thể khai thác
Và rất dễ bị nhiễu
Tiếp theo là với kết quả mô hình City Gun thì trạng thái cũng đều bị chặn
Thì ở đây là mô hình CTGAN thì có dấu hiệu thiên về lỗi Error Bay như là có các câu lệnh như K-Square hoặc là có dấu hiệu chuyển sang Time Bay
Và ở đây thì dữ liệu là so với 2 mô hình trên thì sẽ có bị nhiễu rất nhiều và bị thiên về các cái nhóm SQL khác
Tiếp theo là đến mô hình si quần gan
Thì ở mô hình si quần gan này thì dữ liệu bị viết vô cùng ngắn
Và hầu hết các dữ liệu vượt qua được tường lửa là do là sinh ra nhiễu
Thì các cái câu lệnh ở đây thì bị mất cấu trúc nghiêm trọng
Và dữ liệu có độ dài vô cùng ngắn
Thể hiện cho việc khả năng mô hình đã bị sụp đổ và chỉ tập trung vào một vài ma an toàn
Và các chuỗi thì đứt gãy và bị sai tử khóa rất nhiều
nhiều ví dụ như là như là mẫu đầu thì A thì thay vì viết là case thì chỉ viết đọc là chữ A hoặc
là pg let for thì là sự kết hợp giữa pg sleep và waiting for delay ở mã số 5 cuối cùng đến với mô
hình sinh sinh quần gan thì ở mô hình của em thì là cũng đã bị chặn khá là nhiều hai mẫu mà vượt
khả năng vượt qua được thì là trong một mẫu đó thì bị lỗi và một mẫu thì thật sự có khả năng
vượt qua và có khả năng khai thác thì ở và các mẫu ở đây thì đều dài hơn và học được
những cái cấu trúc phức tạp hơn thể hiện cho việc là môi
hình SQL GAN có khả năng học được các hàm phức tạp
Tuy nhiên nguyên nhân chính của việc nó không vượt qua đây là bởi vì nó vẫn chưa học được chính xác các cấu trúc ngữ pháp chính
Và vẫn còn bị viết sai, bị lẫn ký từ rất nhiều
Ví dụ như là WAVE FOR DELAY
Vậy kết luận đến kết luận cuối cùng
thì là các mô hình
Mod, GAN và CT GAN
thì có giữ được cầu trúc SQL tốt
do chỉ hầu hết là để
truy hồi lại các payload săn có
có các dấu hiệu tấn công rõ ràng
và WAV đã nhận diện được
và đều bị chặn toàn bộ
thì nhóm phương pháp trên có độ đồng nhất
độ đồng nhất thấp, trùng lập cao
và ít tạo ra các biến thể mới
có khả năng thử thách với các tương lửa
còn mô hình SQL GAN
thì sinh ra dữ liệu
mất cân bằng
sinh ra dữ liệu mất cân bằng mạnh
do là mô hình đã sụp đổ sớm
dẫn tới việc là sinh ra các dữ liệu vô cùng ngắn
và bị sai cấu pháp rất là nhiều
và các dữ liệu đều bị mất đi hết ý nghĩa SQL
còn đối với mô hình SQL GAN cải tiến của em
thì là đã được cải thiện
và đã xử lý được những vấn đề
mà mô hình SQL GAN cơ bản gặp phải
và có duy trì cấu trúc SQL rõ rệt hơn
và tường lửa thật sự nhận diện
các cái payload đấy và đã chặn chủ động chặn
còn xét về chất lượng tổng thể
thì chỉ có 2
family là
có kết quả khả quan là Bolan và Union
còn đối với Tam và Aaron
thì có chỉ số rất là thấp
do là phải học cả đến
có các cú pháp
và hàm phụ thuộc mạnh
vào từng hệ quản trị
cơ sở dư liệu riêng
thì riêng phần này
thì nếu như mà muốn cải thiện được
thì bản thân em sẽ cần phải có
phân tách riêng ra
nghĩa là sẽ phải phân ra bộ dữ liệu
chỉ riêng cho Postgre
hoặc là bộ dữ liệu chỉ
Postgre
bộ dữ liệu chỉ phân cho SQL
LINE
thì khi đó thì mô hình mới không bị học lẫn
giữa các cái
từng hệ quản trị cơ sở dữ liệu
và phần trình bày của em đến đây là hết
trình bày của em diễn ra
21 phút thì em
biết là thầy có phần nào
thế là em trình bày nó có phần dài dòng
và cần phải cắt bớt